Daniel Bobo curling Babu is on his way
in
you might know him from Twitter yeah he
at one point had a show on compound
media I believe off the air bubble and
Bo Shetty is telling her on the night
now it didn't it was not a hit with the
audience well we'll find out yeah
he's trying to prop that coat up on the
chair tougher than it looks on my right
boobs yeah it is all right now Daniel
let's ask you really quickly now before
we begin you did commit to doing the
chip podcast today is that correct yep
that's right 6:30 p.m.
yep okay and Sam is gonna want you to go
down with him so after shows your guy
he'll spend time together and then go
down to the podcast together
unfortunately Bobo has a lot to do this
afternoon so we'll just have to meet up
at the podcast you can meet up before no
comment a lot to do and whatever it'll
it'll work either way all right I like
the positive attitude yeah that's right
you too easy here's the thing about Bobo
that makes him better than most people
is them they're in time for the show um
there that's right yes right that's
actually great philosophy yeah well I'm
there on time for the show on there
you're right Bob always a doer yeah
whereas a lot of people are sailors they
come in here you know what I'm saying
but they come in and they go like this
is what my plan is
this is what I'm gonna possibly try to
get done this is what my goal is what
was like this is what I'm doing
yep and as long as I'm there on time I'm
there because if you're not on time what
are you I'm late
that's right so now Daniel what happened
you had a show on compound media what
was it called no there's a this was
something that it was there was a Bobo
and Bichette II think that's planned
into works they had snow in them because
I done shows yet yet but we did we did
do a we did do like a little pop up cuz
he needed to fill some stuff out before
they before they had their third third
third they're mourning God they're
mourning guy announced right bill
Schultz yeah yeah it should have been
you guys but I know I know there's gonna
be there's gonna be like some kind of
they're gonna have some time slaughter
side
figure it out alright that that's that
what they're still working on the timing
how did Bill Schulz get the gig instead
of Bobo and Bo Shetty I think that one
was playing because they want because I
think that time sought they that was
that was saying they kind of wanted
something similar in a time slot because
they because they had cuz they Gavin
McGinnis had it what's he talking about
he has no idea is Roy no I'm asking why
did why did why did Bill Schulz get the
gig and not Bobo Shetty they want to
sign that had a little new Z elements oh
you guys don't do the news yet yeah
there might there might be some new
sometimes ever news happen so it does
have a news Alamut to it yeah but it's
not really does it doesn't have like an
element that looks like the new Daniel
into the microphone element that looks
like it doesn't have like an element
that looks like you knew you guys are
more fun and freestyle yeah exactly so
they asked it yeah it just kind of wild
yeah yeah kind of yeah
shock jock hurry yeah yeah yeah can your
desertion crazy news of the day joke to
the day it's all kind of it's it's off
the rails believe me there there there
there there sub it's planned in it that
that III haven't nope I have a little
computer file what one what's one what a
computer fine watch out for those things
yes oh my god I got stuff I got stuff on
file in case uh like what one bit that
you guys are thinking this is what we'll
do when spud he gets launched well well
one of the bits I thought I thought of
was uh try to see who try to get flat
flashed in every state we've been to so
a good set you want to go from state to
state trying to get women to show you
their breasts well in good timing too so
you want to get girls to flash you in
every state now yeah I would love to
have seen that happen to me
oh boy you listen to the Opie and
Anthony show a bunch right yeah does
that seem at all derivative I don't know
if it's only good like I'm not like I'm
couraging people to like bass bass
flashing if they doesn't remind you of
the whippin out
a little bit a little bit
I don't know that like I guess I just
broke down stuff I what else you get
that soft what's another so the first
bit is like getting women to ship but
instead of see women mount Wednesday
would be like women would show audience
members their breasts Bobo's ideas for
women to show the host yeah okay cool
rests and if he's breathing in a very
comfortable volume yes right
Oh what else we breathe through our nose
yeah yeah oh one one of the things I
like to do harass telemarketers okay
yeah fine right cool does that seem at
all like it's been like you mean my jim
Florentine does or different maybe you
put your own spin on it
well well Jim for jim Florentine did a
CD about harassing telemarketers it's
just me I'm trying to purposely get them
me as more me my grudge versus
telemarketers because I get it why not
okay I'm trying to get some to leave me
alone
Oh different angle now when you did your
pop-up show where did you do that we did
that at the compound media studios see
you didn't announce he just kind of
popped up and talked they they add they
asked me to come they asked me to come
in the day before and do do this so it
was announced yeah it would evolve well
it was announced all fear to me to the
Townsend announcement but I oh you're
saying how did it go the show bike I
think I think it went great who takes
the lead I think we can't we kind of we
kind of both take the lead but Marc at
the same time I do kind of like to give
a little Mike Bocchetti at seniority
because he's been around for a while
sure and you're more the comic relief
anyway right yeah yeah come with the
jokes yeah exactly
what's one of the subjects you guys
covered well well one of the things we
were covering it's about how I like how
how I how I think a female Met fans have
the best we have the best females fans
in baseball what makes you think that I
don't know they just seem very
attractive
remember that time that you were
actually on the field that's
field and and you know how is that the
reporter Alexa Alexa dad was asking you
like Mets trivia question you ain't know
the time I missed I misheard that last
question that I I was like in like some
big situation try to remember trying to
process the questions in a certain
amount it was a question what I thought
she said was who hit the most home runs
during the 86 postseason what did she
actually ask because I was not being
common processing it quickly how did she
say was a real question who hit the boat
what Mets pitcher hit the most home runs
during the regular season 86 okay just
totally different question yes again
let's just go over this I think you're
right the audio of it I entered the
question what is your giant Mets fan you
get to be on Citi Field next to a
beautiful woman in a convertible car I
mean what are you nervous yeah I was
nervous and they I got the answer wrong
because they Prague I like just clips am
I know the reporter and so I got to be
like oh my god you just met Bobo
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay Cincinnati is correct a coincidence
two right answers yeah we have good
audio anywhere who would know it's just
from the stadium fees although there was
intelligence how it's always been
yeah let's see what
Tom Glavine Coronets the second one what
med pitcher blast Mets pitcher to Homer
in a consecutive start was the last best
Mets pitcher to homer in consecutive
starts you thought the question was who
who hit the most home runs during the
1986 postseason well I was I was in a
rush like not processing it quicker
sometimes when you get nervous you just
make up your own questions in your head
no but maybe I was just processing it a
little bit differently he says because
all the noise in the RBI thing that
tunnel-like sure what was the actual
question the the actual question was
what met pitcher hit the most homeruns
starts I think when the last met picture
the whole race starts it's been a while
since I watch this video who's the last
Mets pitcher to homer in consecutive
starts yeah and you thought it was and
because I answered it like the Komodo
did you say what that was a question I
thought it was the quote the the
question I thought they were asking was
who hit the most homeruns 386 postseason
because because they told because I I
kind of got a little hint of what the
question was gonna be oh they didn't
tell me the question but they gave me
the hint like okay like frosting go at
him yeah who's this quiz show yeah we
won't give you the question yeah
but they said the question somehow is
tied to the 1986 CS and so I'm just I
don't think do you think that they said
that to him because I don't think that
they do know supposed to be a million
and they gave it to him wrong let's see
the question maybe you get it right
Lenny Dykstra's on a picture of
hesitation and then he said Lenny
Dykstra and the answer was Ron darling
Ron darling what say yeah you said Lenny
Dykstra I I am bummed out I missed heard
that question because you might have
misheard it but I mean yeah by mister
that yeah 86 postseason none of that
meant anything to do I know where you
Thurman Munson would have been a better
guest
so so when she said no the correct
answer is Ron darling did you look at
her like Alexa debt you are a crazy
woman there's no way there are darling
no no but then I looked at the thing and
I thought Ron darling I thought
something because at the time I was
hearing Ron darling talk about this
something a lot in the broadcast booth
how I had to you know like I'll say yeah
I hit two homeruns in consecutive starts
oh and as soon as I heard that I can't
be into that that whole thing because I
during the course of season I forgot so
like use that happen and then you're
watching and Ron darling is on
commentary and he's like hey you know I
hit consecutive starts home runs in
consecutive starts and it would remind
you of the time you were humiliated in
the center of the place where you feel
most comfortable yeah and I fir and I've
heard him talk about this before that
before the day that this this video was
filmed so you sure yeah and somehow be
I'm he bought me that I misheard the
quest the question yeah on something
that front darling brags about a lot so
you blew it big time
it wasn't that tough of a question is
what you're saying yeah if I would if I
would have heard it right and maybe
maybe it maybe not made up half the
question yeah or maybe not and maybe
listened a bit more carefully right well
that's a that's a that's a good lesson
to learn what when we listen we we do
better that's right we do is there any
audio of the Bocchetti and uh Bobo show
mastic we have it I mean I
I think you'd have to so compound
question yeah as thank you as a Mets fan
er baseball fan what was a cooler moment
being on on the field answering those
questions or throwing out a first pitch
I think probably through its throat
throwing out a first pitch did you throw
out a first pitch I threw out a first
pitch at a Brooklyn Cyclones game do we
have footage of how was that heard you
did a good job that that was that was
one that I was nervous because people
were not cuz I'm my mother I was my
mother was running late should you say I
was she fell did not what she got there
on she just barely got there on time to
see it what an unfortunate because III
let ila I left earlier to my mother did
because I didn't trust my aunt to be
driving cuz I I never trust her to be
very punctual sure it's important to
throw this in well let's see can we find
Bobo's first pitch because I'd like to
see I mean if Bobo did well you know
yeah I mean you know the nerves are one
thing but you know III think that did
you get past him I think it kind of I
think it kind of fell in front of the
plate let me see you don't think it made
the plate all the way well I was trying
to give the hat tip to my to my to my
mother insists and I'd like to thank a
good friend of mine al for filming this
for me you shouldn't you shouldn't thank
him for well he went with me on the
field to film this at the time I wanted
to get this on film but after the pitch
did you still want it on film well
because it it happened it and because
they think was only right that people
seen it that it did happen ago you're
right that's actually grateful yes I
want to see the captive again okay like
just like just like the captain right
yeah just coming out there come on out
Derek
yeah it's a very quick horse here the
Yankee captain IQ of two all right here
he is at the bottom of the mound and
what the [ __ ] was that what will you
have to know like a did you not practice
you know the thing about pitching is you
have to know when to release right
I was practicing it I was practicing it
but and I said that that last-minute
nerve is on the way off the field okay
so he throws the pitch on the ground
like not it doesn't hang on hit pause
because it doesn't just not make home
plate I mean it rolled
he literally throws it a foot in front
of them in hits the ground no see the
pitch again yes yes please
I think that like if a professional
bowler would look at that and say good
form well done yeah well maybe this
wasn't as bad the hold on maybe Bobby he
just didn't release the right time let's
take a line let's take a look let's see
he's up on the mound and we'll tweet out
this video forever and immediately he
just throws it and right to the ground
hits a dirt of the mound and then
bounces it hits the dirt of the
pitcher's mound yeah so because the
pitcher's mound there would be maybe a
foot in front of him maybe it didn't
even go a foot and they just rolled
there I was always tell I was telling my
sister that that time when I was privacy
in the backyard I said we wheat all this
time we should have practiced on on an
actual baseball diamond right thank you
that was a I said there's there's a
baseball field what not you practice on
Marie's pork and apprentice and I know
well in a backyard in the backyard in
the backyard of a dollhouse no no no the
backyard of my house oh I told my sister
I think I think I would've felt I feel
more cut I would have felt more
confident back to sing shark the thing
on it on a on a baseball diamond
I don't know [ __ ] wasn't that bad
released a little early and you could
tell too when you're in a backlit
released a little late when you're in a
backyard throw-in the ball
and it and it goes eight inches that can
feel like like you don't know until
you're on a baseball team and that eight
inches does not make it a point a home
right yeah exactly what looks like when
you like that's why I could a ruler out
when I'm watching a baseball game on TV
and it is eight inches from the
pitcher's mound of home plate I don't
have the biggest TV in the world but it
is eight inches yeah I mean you really
so little late I mean it when you threw
that did you like I wouldn't mind having
that one back exactly exactly that's
what it is I didn't I would have loved
to have prior I admit if I wouldn't if I
could go into a time machine I would
have told myself
make sure you emphasize with your sister
we gotta you gotta actually go with me
Shannon you gotta go with me to maurice
park practice on the baseball diamond
there good use of a time machine what
else would you do a time machine maybe I
maybe I tell a certain friend not to not
to not to let let not to let your
girlfriend use periscope are you talking
oh I'm glad wouldn't stop 911 no baby
sister go to the ball field with him and
he'd stop Anthony from playing with his
girlfriend yeah well maybe I pull a John
McLean and stop 911 maybe when you threw
that pitch did you know that it was a it
was a little late you released it could
you tell everybody not sure I think I
felt it after after I released it like
did you know that you had thrown a bit a
ball that you probably could have you
would like to have redone or were you
satisfied with the pitch in the moment
as it's happening you don't know if it's
gonna make it or not yeah like when you
released that you weren't sure if it was
gonna make the plate or not yeah and
then when did you realize it was again
him it was it was it when the guy came
over was it the nanosecond after you
throw it and hit the dirt two inches in
front of you know when I said when I saw
the ball start to drop I felt like start
to drop you threw it you kind of throw
it into the dirt yeah technically the
ball started to drop before you released
it we see this again yeah like show me
Daniel at what point did you realize
that this is one you'd like back here
you are the old appropriate tippity-tap
tip of the hat that's right relief
pitcher
here yep that doesn't make you cargo
shorts foolish yeah cargo shorts a good
at gaming yokes is quick to the mound
and doing old-time movies wait let's go
back yeah it is like watching Babe Ruth
let's let's stay I'll say when you're
gonna throw the pitch and when it hits
the dirt because I wanted to know when
in your mind you realize that this might
not be the best pitch this is a good
exercise yeah okay here we go
you're walking out okay now he's on the
mound and he is ready to throw he goes
the pitch dirt okay okay yeah so there
was a very very small amount of time
between the actual release and the dirt
when did you realize that it was going
towards the dirt and maybe when the ball
the the air kind of okay I get that I
don't understand that answer no like I
felt when the ball was in the air it
might not in the air was it like when
you would you mean when you when you
were holding it on you threw it directly
into the dirt no one liked the ball when
I release the boy you release that you
realized that it wasn't going forward it
was going directly into the dirt
technically do you say release if
instead of pitching the ball you just
dropped it yeah
would you still say that there's a
release ball it did it it's no longer in
your hand that's actually true yeah
you're right yes true no you're right so
do you regret that one or do you think
that it was like people probably didn't
notice honestly did anybody say anything
people saw it on the internet or write
these yeah but it wasn't that bad of a
like like you have to like look closely
alright yeah I didn't quite make the
play when they saw it on youtube did
most people say actually that really
wasn't bad well it was good
I saw people said I may have been better
than a Baba Booey I may have been better
than a 50 cent actually I saw the Baba
Booey pitch and his his was better than
yours because it actually went some
distance it didn't go near the home
plate but neither did yours you know you
threw your ball to the pitcher's mound
yeah I mean people did comment on the
video that it was a good pitch they did
yeah what does it say nice bow bow that
throw was steeped in folly Bobo's got
some heat in that arm there you go
you're the man bow bow I see that Bobo
right on Bobo I've never seen anything
like that Bobo holy amazing yeah
yeah there you go okay so you got your
support that's pretty [ __ ] cool Bobo
I hope you had a blast once said I got
it further than 50 Cent's did 50 Cent's
we have an issue to discuss before we
discuss the issue would you like to see
a mags at the field yeah I want to see
the executer this is it's an exited
victory yeah okay so he gets off the
mound
what'd the guy say to you no I fit I
didn't really I didn't talk to the guy
yeah guy said NASA just took took the
picture and that was it yes so what
happens here you threw a pretty good
pitch no not perfect but okay but okay
the guy comes over to you he takes a
nice photo with you you have that
hanging up in your room I get I got I
got a copy of the photo Hank did that'll
be and I might hang up on my room one
day what are you waiting for
yes hey they don't mind it be spending
on frames left and right that's also a
good quote write that but I do I do want
to frame one day plus that I got I I
have to do some repainting in my room
sure sure she wants just just stains on
the wall ceiling no just just the room
needs it needs to be just needs to be
repainted fresh coat huh yeah don't eat
those chips but that just needs to be
repainted but it's not the repaints not
high on a priority list but eventually
it's gonna be my room's gonna be
repainted I just realized that like do
you understand yep
the Ed McMahon - chips Johnny Carson the
Bobo is going to be I think they're
gonna be terrific together he's going to
laugh everything chip says only if he
thinks it's funny bubble is a tough
audience
he's discerning what's that noise what
are you doing more than your slacks have
gotten a little tighter
yeah are you buying smaller pants Daniel
no no you know I can't look tighter than
the less
we know it's just there's thermals
underneath it oh they make the pants a
little tighter okay cool all right let's
watch every thermals under your chin all
right cool here we go here we go oh look
one more time toys toys home plate a
little tip of the cap of that good you
got to keep the ball and then you
stopped almost to take a moment you
enjoyed the some would say indifference
but I think it was a nice rousing round
of applause I do too
yeah yeah might fame might the by family
a gig gimme gave me a nice round of
applause now let's go back to say to the
second tipped row you can see them kind
of going crazy you're watching yeah
let's say wanted you to stop watch let's
see the audience you can hear it yeah it
makes the
and there's the sparsely spread out
audience they're going crazy for you
though some right to mine it's a
minor-league game oh it's alright Major
League talent like yourself yeah I want
to see a little bit of Daniel show with
machete I think in my potential and
maybe we could steal this from compound
media we don't have it it's behind the
paywall everything oh we don't have an
account with them you have an account
did you keep the ball Bobo made me pay
for Nick yes I do have the ball pity
where is it it thought it's on my shelf
very nice Bobo going now wait what was
better this show or the David and Bobo
show I think this show was kind of
better only because a date because David
runs from anybody connected to him
diversity work from those days green
shirt yeah he said he made the mistake
of wearing an invisibility cloak right
no is that his shirt it looks like a
green like
fleece I yeah he's disappeared I think I
think I did make a comment of it I said
I said Bocchetti
he looks like Bechet decides to wear an
invisibility cloak today I see you come
with the jokes he said that a minute ago
yeah yeah but I'm just saying I did say
that I wanted to say what did you tell
him when you saw that I think I think I
just made that that that comment about
gentleman about the invisibility cloak
oh you [ __ ] child
yeah boo Shetty uh I guess made the
mistake of wearing some kind of white
green fleece because in the video that
we're watching
he's transparent his body has been
green-screen down his body's never
looked better actually that's right okay
let's see why are you both scratching I
don't know why he's doing scratching at
the same time but I figured I'm the one
he's for doing the rapping I'm doing the
scratching scratching the desk
no but I'm making the motion oh they
could put it in post let me hear it
again I mean like if someone wanted to
do like a Photoshop of a picture of me
scratching that's right I'm sure that's
what they would have you doing yeah
[Music]
scratch when I go
his name is kill me he is so cool hey
Lang because he's not a fool his crew is
ready to go
he's got Keith the cop and Arenberg it's
good muscle in the groove but biscottis
our fruit hope you listen as you know
scratch Brennan in East Side Dave's it's
weird the bisetti estate all phony and
filled with rage rage rage
don't forget ally she's like handing in
a major babe all the haters and trolls
stick to Jon Stewart and Pauly Shore
Bobo and me making some noise we're
gonna bank some [ __ ] before this a
sign-up compound media compound media
compound media today today today today
that's good you've maintained a certain
motion how did I not notice that that a
that a machete was trying to make the
scratching motion between are you
worried about your own thing you're not
worried yeah yeah I didn't die I kind of
know it's like little things when you
watch these things so yeah let me see if
I said this is what hold on why didn't
you make the sound of scratching because
if you listen to it you could just kind
of hear in the background just like yeah
what well because I wanted to leave room
for let's say if someone wants to likely
you know like maybe sneak and put an
audio of like a scratching sound
I see like what sound like like yeah
I've been scratching it's good one more
times we get clean audio of it video
that big finishing pounded out that was
actually good would be a clean audio
though so if somebody does put it in
they have clean audio of it not bad oh
my god not bad now let's let's let me
see this again front of the second was
good thanks Dan I should have been a
rapper but I think I missed my thing in
life right yeah you did what about his
hold on a second
shetty's [ __ ] transparent yeah what
the [ __ ] with this dumb shirt it's
interfering with the green screen why is
it what is he doing well there's certain
colors you can't wear with green screen
yeah you can't wait you can't wear green
when you're doing when you're on train
screen how did you not notice that I
noticed it when he was doing it
what did you say lead him there was a
point in the show where I made ray stuck
in a line saying looks like Mike decided
to wear an invisibility cloak today a
good comedian will acknowledge who's
your least favorite person on this earth
you're a good guy but I know you have
some rage like me we both though well
I'm not gonna mention a name but just
just some boss that under underpaid me
here's a here's a jackass I know you
tell me about this piece of garbage but
you know what then you're on your way
who cares exactly right now then what's
the deal with money I can't see him what
did he wear my bow I'm invisible
invisibility cloak I was thinking that
in my head when he said that how long
was this give me a four-hour show I
think maybe an hour just pop-up they
should do it longer we got to get to uh
of course why I was here the main piece
of business yeah Bobo I'm doing first of
all yeah I heard there was an
unfortunate mishap yeah my mom still is
in on-and-off pains okay she still has
to go go through therapy intense therapy
by the way all right I'm recovering from
an injury like that you see when
athletes come back from a bad injury
they got to go through intense physical
therapy that's true stuff it's true
there was an issue there's a couple of
subreddits one is like don't fund me and
I don't remember what the other one is
called but they're dedicated to fake
GoFundMe pages that are not the funds
are not being
used for what their accurately claiming
that there are and Bobo you are one of
the top threads on these things people
say that you've had this GoFundMe up for
a year because your mom slipped and foul
and then hurt her they don't and they're
not getting all the facts street what
does it say sorry to interrupt you
Daniel what did it say in the actual
thing when you were looking for money
well what was your little thing that you
put well I don't remember the whole word
from this cuz my sister typed up the
whole thing show her perspective what
happened now explain so you're getting
this money right because your mom needs
help
alright but you've been going to many
sports games since then you went to many
Mets games
you bought a tablet at one point you oh
no I was at the time this thing was
still going man bear in mind these
tickets were weren't you give it to me
as a gift from a from a friend of the
family all right
okay I'm not I don't use charity money
on first stuff it's not supposed to be
you're saying you deny these allegations
um Denine these allegations right all
right I would I would not stoop to a low
like that oh okay money right I don't I
don't control the GoFundMe who does a
family member and the money is used for
the medical expenses only how'd you get
that tablet I had that that tablet was a
gift end doing sugar daddy who's gifting
you know first of all I had that tablet
before the incident also but what is
what's this what's to say here but I
came to reading my Asha bed
okay and who's the picture it's your
mama's at you hit the mic that photo was
taken at a man party there's also
accusations of your sister traveling the
country world traveling the world first
of all my sister she was studying abroad
nice no no I did that mean
that means overseas oh and for one thing
she was also working and when he had
free time she did she did stuff but
she's so well how is she funding these
trips that it what it wasn't it was it
was her own money right but it wasn't
GoFundMe money where did she get the
money from she get the would she had to
work there were there were times she
worked at at a hospital oh okay
during that during that during when she
studied abroad she worked at a hospital
so what do you feel how do you feel that
these allegations of misappropriated
funds I hate them I hate that troll i
also was talking to some people on a
fellow a compound media person was
talking to me about this and he says
don't worry about this there that same
person's going his attacking his
attacking anthony oh ok was the person
that compound media you were talking to
right i was talking about was having
conversations with pat nixon okay we got
the information idea was tough yeah okay
you do you do is tell you usually don't
fold under questioning we have somebody
wants to ask a question okay
now dan i hope this is legit let's say
this is legit hello Dan hey guys how you
doing
okay and the show a huge fan of Bobo um
my question is I want to get his
thoughts on the fact that he site Dave
is now [ __ ] his mother Izzie said
David having sex with you it's a little
harsh to answer that way did he he no he
never did but there is a joke of running
bit that he does on the show where he
hits on my mom it is an act is it though
yeah he isn't really doing anything with
myself divorced or is he going to
divorce he daily divorced your mom is
single thank you oh yeah thank you you
know what Saved by the Bell
they were all pretending to date each
other but if you watch the Lifetime
movie which I have many times they were
dating each other and
life - yeah a lifetime movie does
overdramatize [ __ ] they say this Daniel
Bobo Carla a lot of truth is said in in
fiction true but it doesn't mean that it
always is real right so sometimes truth
is stranger then sometimes truth is
stranger than fiction
that's right absolutely correct so maybe
your mom's having sex with with East
Side days yes
now some Tony Danza donated to the fun
that's pretty cool
no some guy pretend said he was Tony dan
so he said thought some prayers and he
donated a ago says his name now is that
still up it's still up but I don't I
don't know if that's the real Tony Danza
okay so that's better say I know you
could put in anything I could put in it
whatever name I wanted to wanna on a go
for me what are some of the names if I
if I wanted to donate on the GoFundMe
why would any but I don't I usually just
hand them money direct to my mom instead
of they go if I want to donate when I
don't eat to her but if you hand the
money directly to your mom then how do
you end up getting the tablet I had that
before the incident wait I want to I
want to see the UM the GoFundMe I want
to see all they all I want to see some
of the names yeah let's see some other
celebrity Barker you must be Bob acre
Bob Barker good luck to your mother some
nice P points yeah Dave McDonald what
that I did get confirmation from Dave
himself that he really did donate thank
oh she's gonna take Steve why wouldn't
he
so your mom did she break her wrist it
was hit like screws in her arms and
there was a hair she screws in her arms
and a hip hip replacement
she had hip replacement surgery done
yeah she had full yep she felt so hard
she has again her hips or her hip
replaced yeah that had to be a hell of a
fall to get hip replacements Wow
is she okay now
she's still in pain she's mending so if
it's it's recovering and everybody I
know that's an expert on this thing told
me it's a long recovery process it's a
long recovery and it doesn't heal
quickly sometimes it might take years
okay I remember there's the end of a
sentence so how long are you gonna leave
up to GoFundMe
because I earned two medical bills kind
of done well until I know that my mom
has doesn't need to worry about the
insurance coverage well is she still
going to the doctor she's still going to
that she still has to go through that
therapy still I see and until she does
how are you gonna go to Florida recently
yeah I I didn't and that was also a
relative was paying for that trip but
they can't sold because he was in town
I'm telling the truth by the way I
didn't say you weren't I'm just saying
people say I'm I believe he is that like
one of Troy's trips Troy goes on gigolo
just showed you of a sugar daddy it's
okay no no I don't have a sugar daddy I
it does sound like you could yeah I mean
it does sound but I don't have a sugar
daddy okay I like the gentleman flying
you around
no well because here's the problem if it
really was your relatives then why
wouldn't your relatives just take the
money that they're spending on your
tickets to Mets games and trips to
Florida and just give it to your mom
they have done that as well
you must have very wealthy relatives no
I don't have but so sometimes the
tickets are cheap oh they do not do not
buying expensive tickets or cheap
tickets they're cheap well said um how
much are they well a little pricey right
no might be give me maybe maybe
somewhere in the 20s maybe three so yeah
III don't know how much might I know and
I know these threes does the sugar daddy
fly you coach a business class if well
my relative my relative
well what's gonna fight it was gonna be
coach I was gonna be flown on okay Troy
got flown business when his uncle flew
him someplace well he that that's it's a
gigolo
bo you're being compared to Bernie
Madoff are you aware of this setup an
ingenious financial scam that she did a
lot of people out of a lot of money and
people are worried that you're doing the
exact same I'm not doing a saint I'm not
doing that cuz my mother if she called
you she would tell you that she's using
that money for her medical expenses of
course your mom she was yeah but because
my mom does not lie Oh true well I'm not
we're not saying she does we're just
we're addressing the allegations as a
news organization right at the end of
the day Jim and I are journalists yeah
we back you and she she would she would
be in a lot worse situation financially
without that go fund me so now what was
your sister traveling to now where is
she - she is in New York okay that's
here yes she is in New York New York the
city that never sleeps
that's right so now I is everyone happy
with the results of the GoFundMe not bad
well I'm sure that they're happy if they
know that my mom and the money is used
for my mom's medical expenses how do you
get the money from GoFundMe do they pay
you monthly yeah I don't know how I
don't know how this works I gotta talk
to the why don't you get it out if you
need to buy it's like shoes or something
how do you get the money out of the
GoFundMe that I don't go I don't I don't
go there right don't don't go don't go
there okay it's a money hire okay the
money is that cuz we I don't use
GoFundMe money I would actually refuse
if I told if if I found if I hear of
anyone trying to do that you wouldn't go
for that no I wouldn't go for that I
even make sure anything it was a anyone
says it I said you're not using money
for that alright because my mom my mom
would not do that she only wants you
some she's only using the money for her
medical advances I mean look there's no
honor and in taking this go fund me
money and Daniel am i right there is no
mana amongst schemers that's right no
honor among scammers yeah so she had her
hip replaced yeah okay now did just you
know if you needed like a quick 20 you
just throw an IOU in there that's fine
no no I would not do that either oh I
would not do that either so your family
controls the GoFundMe money yeah we're a
family you don't have to say their name
but an uncle in addition a sister sister
mom brother yourself I'm not gonna
mention a relative the relation of okay
every dad a respecter is she younger
than you but at a respectability and
it's not being it's not being used for
anything good my mom's medical issue
older a younger you don't the same who
it is younger than me okay she is you
don't have to say right now when you go
to Florida the dad even flies you down
III had I haven't been to Florida since
2015 okay oh so your daddy flies up no I
know it's no one that's flying upper
right is it a coincidence my kids do
visit from time to time sure it's right
I believe you I don't think you're
taking the money you know what they say
you can pick your nose you can pick your
friends but you can't pick your
relatives that's right they do say that
that's right now when you end up being
gifted a Mets ticket or a trip or
whatever it is from a family member
does it ever coincide with a fortune and
especially fortunate time with the
GoFundMe meaning that while you are
unaware of where the funds are coming
from no I am giving proof of where it's
from
where's no so this is to silence the
haters right what's the proof Hatter's
Hatter's because I know my relative that
runs
to go for me would not lie okay and this
not only has she lied in the past never
has lied never lied okay she's never
lied okay so she's never lied to you um
and you know her since she's a kid so
she you trust her
yeah if she lives in the same house
thank you you're gonna catch her in a
lie right yeah exactly
all right I don't think you you miss use
the phone I don't think so I mean your
mom seems like an honest lady but
actually he is Andrew on Staten Island
has an observation Missy it should be
brought into the conversation okay
Andrew let's let's figure this out
what's up hey good morning guys hello
Bobo's not lying about the sugar daddy
beat sugar daddy being a family member
it's actually his brother who has sex
with it's not him and I never slept with
my brother you didn't use the go fund me
movie money to get a hotel room at the
Queen's Motor Inn I never did okay
all right Andrew I'm glad you brought
that thank you
making allegations Daniel how do you
respond to those allegations
go screw yourself lawyer okay yeah good
for you you could decide in item right
an item but I read you also you want him
to go screw herself yeah exactly so when
did you get way would do this hurt your
feelings and people thought this about
you it hurts my feelings big time when I
hear this why because you think that
people should think of you is more
honorable they should think of you more
as like they shouldn't think of you as
like a supervillain that breathes
heavily exactly I I think that is the
lowest all right whoa
to do that steal money from a go for me
I would not do that I think that is it
would be like cutting your own son's
hand off in a lightsaber duel yeah
exactly that's absolutely I would I
would not do that
good I'm glad to hear it
Plus that Plus that I would never do
anything that Bernie Madoff
I would never pull Bernie Madoff scam if
any cuz you're not a I'm not a lawyer if
anything
Bernie Madoff Fred Wilpon 's budget
who's Fred Wilpon owner the Mets Oh back
it back home runs is the starter no but
Bernie Madoff the everything of Lenny
Dykstra Bernie Madoff may have hurt the
Mets financially how long did this Lenny
Dykstra pitch for he never did never did
he never did he never did because the
question was about pitchers that hit
home runs and you said Lenny Dykstra I
already told you I didn't hear that
question correctly okay fair enough
okay look and this is only so we can get
everything on the table we do have a
call on line three
let's just get it out yeah let's just
hello that is a guy pretending to be my
brother i oh no no no no I know my
brother's voice and that's not his voice
really whoa all right I got hung up so
maybe he was no he wasn't okay but he
said he was anybody could call in and
say that cuz no one's ever heard my
brother's voice how many people know you
have a brother not that many they know
they know I do but they've never heard
the voice how do they know you have a
brother I never heard it I mentioned him
before
oh but they've never worked ice somebody
on Twitter reported you your your
GoFundMe to police
why are you reporting Bobo there's no
evidence she's just mad cuz I blocked
this [ __ ] she trolls Oh everybody who
is she I'm a troll that's what she is a
troll but where's ready you ever send
her flirty messages no I never did
before this I never did good for you
cuz up up hers right yep up hers yeah or
him cuz you might be but you might be
some scam artist yeah you got a message
for her right up your nose with a
with a knife Wow Ryan but it's effective
that is yeah that's super effective man
Wow um when did you start getting
enemies on the Internet Bobo I don't
understand this organize I don't need to
take down Bobo because I like Bobo I
think you said I enjoy your guy you
should drive me crazy but I've learned
to enjoy anybody that has any kind of
celebrity sense has their enemies okay
people that think it's cool to troll
people cuz they cuz they're not that
person so you say that your celebrity
probably turns people off yeah people
just want to troll cuz they're not me
because you're jealous of success yeah
wait wait Bob are you saying they hate
us because they ain't us oh wow now do
you consider yourself a major celebrity
or minor celebrity I listen I think I
may be low level well I'm a minor
celebrity what letter would you get
there's a list there's B list and
there's you know some on the C list I
guess where would you put yourself as a
celebrity I might be d-list well well I
know maybe I maybe I think maybe I may
be famous enough that maybe inside a
foreign country might I think I could um
I feel like I could maybe trick to some
Japanese into thinking I'm famous
why would you have to do that if you're
already famous yeah
well maybe maybe a bit more you well how
do you feel right now let's just let's
just call this what it is how do you
feel about the fact that Troy is looking
for your sisters Instagram account while
you're sitting in the room what's wrong
that it's a public account it's a
private account she actually has it
private on the line so just to keep
people creepy because I I've warned
people saying about she doesn't want
she's a civilian in this whole that's
true not unlike you yeah she's a
civilian she's not a celebrity yeah
exactly and I don't want peopIe don't
want people bothering her she's up how
long's your sister she's in there she's
in the early 20s okay any problem with
that Troy attractive it's kind of
surprising well she's very cute but yes
how do you feel about Troy like I'd
holler at your sister boo boo
how do you feel about that problem fine
get that's fine it's just shin doesn't
want to deal with any relations or any
kind of relation e act any sexual
activity of any kind at right good girl
good you don't want to deal with that
stuff we have Bobo's mom is on the phone
okay we should absolutely talk to her
yeah hello this is some person from
that's not my mother
hold on a second let's hear how
unfortunate ly Bobo scared her off
she hung that's because that's not my
mother cuz I know what my mother sounds
like it could be your mother after all
my mother may be in a weak signal area I
know my mother's real voice Bobo it
could be your mother after all home is
where where the heart is absolutely you
know I know what my mother's real voice
sounds like and I know that's not her
wel koude danya's mother call back if
that's unless that's not her it sounded
like that's not her that's not her I'll
let you determine definitely I mean Jim
to you I couldn't hear cuz he yelled
over it so it sounds like it could be it
might have been I don't know that's not
her I could I could put I could put my
real mother on the phone right now
that's okay no no we'll let her call it
no that's okay no she does she doesn't
know the number to call it I don't know
if you guys changed the number don't
worry yeah so I don't did I just see a
picture of you jumping into money where
is that let me oh my god but jewels are
doing the Photoshop do you I don't know
that is your face that's a Photoshop do
you have a giant pool of coin first of
all do not jump into a big pool of coins
because you will break your [ __ ] neck
yeah and first of all I do not own a
pool like that you'd have to be crazy to
do that why did where do you put all the
money people I I don't know a lot of
money but I put it in a bank like
everyone else
Oh baby buddy you got your mom fake mom
fake mom fake mom oh we ever talk to you
there's something you would only answer
something you would only know
hold on a second yes that's not my mom's
voice to the control over your piece
Bobo Bobo yes listen
Bobo thank you for coming on Jim and Sam
show my mother does not have a driver's
license that wasn't her I hung up on her
I have to ask I mean you know yeah it
was not my mom okay let's see here's one
here Tuesday's Bobo's mom yeah all we
can do is I mean is the screener in
there trying to weed out the fakes
yes Yeah right now all right try to weed
out the face I don't know which I've
talked to her she's a lovely woman she
sounds like you can't get angry though
yeah hold on
let's see hello boys mom this is Bobo's
mom just say hello hello hey that's not
my mama doodoo yes well well red please
my mom does not smoke all right I'm
gonna take my word for it he doesn't
smoke if you hang it up on the fake good
for you I mean if his mom doesn't smoke
the evidence is right there that as it
was a four it was a phony if if if
someone can give me a piece of paper
with the with the phone number two :
I could call my mom and I could call to
speak to the real you got my actual
monitor okay so yeah hello how you doing
hello Bobo's mom that's you're not
that's not my for sure we don't know for
sure I will get my hold on boy hold on
yes hello are you Bobo's mom or no
what's going on boys mom well there's
been a been a great mystery in Bobo's
life oh yes he was adopted not adopted I
really did come out of my mom's vagina
okay I have to be you as it turned me he
came out of his real relaxed Daniel or
look up the phone number just call in to
the Jim and Sam show Daniel I want I
want them to speak to a real person
getting to the bottom of this Bobo we're
getting to the bottom of it we're like
no no but I'm just offended by the
people that are calling pretending to be
you we are weeding them out though yeah
ask her why she never told you you were
da Bao land right okay yeah we are
getting to the bottom all right they
leave that she called it here we go
there she is hello here we go okay hello
brothers Milo Hey Bobo's feather hey we
need to put it into these genetic sexual
hang-up
so man 5 we're getting through people
pretending to be my mother and I want
the real person all right here we go you
just told her the call here she is there
she is hello is this publish mom hello
hello hey another fake hold on hello
another face my mother does not have a
British accent I'm leaving your father
for a woman's well one thing how could
you leave my father if you know my dad
is dead Daniel corner where to go fist
bump me on em oh boy I am a fat [ __ ]
that right I know this benefit but
there's one thing that does after is
senators of any people pretending to be
my mother okay
goodbye that I'm gonna fended by that
people can all be my mother
we assumed it was your mother and you
know what happens when we assume you
make an ass out of you and me well at
least one of the two mm-hmm you make an
ass out of you and me all right here we
go we do have boys mom okay here we go
hello Bobo's mother hello better beat a
real one
let's see Bobo's mom just say yes oh
hello yeah Clemmy the numbers are
dropping
another dude another dude okay mom ask
you a question only your mom would know
the answer to mom I asked a question
that only your mom would know does the
hospital you were born in exist still
yeah she hump you know what he huh you
were right you nailed them dude you got
him Bobo will go for one more this is
the right time I think this is her
actually okay
hello bubbles mom hello hello yes hey
that's not my mother
have sex with my brother oh all right I
never have
don't believe that my real mother would
know that okay I never did good so you
don't like people pretending to be your
mom yeah I don't I don't like that at
all
and you didn't yeah I don't think Daniel
stole any money I don't think so at all
I don't think those accusations are
false I would encourage people to donate
to the GoFundMe yeah his mom's a lovely
lady
there's moms are wonderful ladies and I
believe in they donate to my real the
real mom my real person Yeah right and
okay maybe this one cuz it sounds like
it's from the right place from Brooklyn
hello it's not from Brooklyn she's from
Queens I know but it's nearby on the
phone twice hold on hold on put on hold
hello I'm offended by people I just want
them to speak to the real person he's on
the phone with his mom okay I tried to
hang up on the fake caller right as it
turns out you can't you can't you can't
go online and look up the phone number
to call it doesn't think that yeah I
know one button III can only do as far
as put you on speakerphone
no no no it we put it on there like that
hover just call it well you can tell her
she's out in the air tell she's on the
air on the air hello you're on the radio
you do know that yes the Daniel - okay
which one but you have to tell you that
before we talk to you okay how are you
feeling do you feel about all the other
people on the internet that are accusing
your son Daniel of misappropriation yeah
being being part of it so he's you know
he's being he's being compared to Bernie
Madoff so you're you're saying there is
no misappropriation
fun's going on with your GoFundMe okay
dad very very annoyed because people are
pretending to be you and we don't know
what you sound like so it's like Daniels
been annoyed that like people who kind
of sound like you have been calling in
what happened that's okay you're welcome
that's all right you very welcome I'm
bummed to hear that you had you had a
mishap as they said an unfortunate and
then fortunate mishap yeah alright we
tried to clarify Daniel Daniel said that
there were some people calling in who
are not you and again we don't know what
you sound like so Daniel was adamant
about getting you on the phone just to
clarify well anytime you'd like to come
in what well I'll make sure that just
tickets left for you if you have you
know it's okay I don't mind your friend
and then Daniel's a friend so yeah I'll
leave tickets free okay thank you well
thank you so much we will uh will leave
tickets for you and we're glad to clear
this up okay yeah very glad all right hi
missus Bobo
alrighty feel better there we go alright
alright so I think that as a show we can
put our support behind
Bobo's GoFundMe well hold on now this is
a false accusation being made against us
where oh line 9 hope he doesn't mean us
yes Nelson in Virginia
hey how's it going hello good hey uh you
know it's it's obvious this dude ain't a
hundred percent I just wondering why the
hell you guys are bullying the dude I
think you're misusing the word bullying
we've known how long we known you Bubba
ten years you've known me since two
doesn't he okay sure almost 10 years
he's been coming on the radio show and
he put on a GoFundMe cuz his mom got
hurt you just heard his mom on the phone
did his mom his mom did she say that
we're treating him badly or did she
thank us for the support we're not
bullying Daniel we're not bullying
Daniel we're lettin Daniel speak and
we're treating Daniel like we treat
everybody else who comes in here what do
you want us to [ __ ] it to kiss him on
the cheek and hold him like he's a child
is a grown man everybody's picking on
the dude man we're not picking on him
people are we can't stop that we I said
I don't think that he misappropriated
then he finds I really don't know we're
clearing up we're clearing up as a show
I don't think he's a real nuts fan I am
I am a real Mets fan well you did think
that uh I know I hate that shake but I
am a real Mets fan okay he made a
horrible blunder but we were trying to
clear up this whole GoFundMe thing
people asked us to talk about it and I
know Daniel wanted to clear it up and we
got his mom on the phone I just it
shames me like you guys are picking on
Addie no we're having no how to follow
someone we've known for 10 years they're
not they're not picking on me if
anything some people pretending to be my
mother
was picking on me they were those people
that were pretending to be my mother was
almost worse than that troll who was
trolling me and was also trolling
Anthony and everybody on his network
we're Bobo's friend all right Nelson
thanks for the call Daniel's father all
right come on we're not bullying Daniel
or bullying is misused sometimes yeah I
mean we're we're having fun with same
way rich Voss or Bob Kelly or anybody
else that comes in here a hundred
percent you have a good time right Bobby
I have a good time because we're your
are but people think that you should be
talked to like you're a child which is
just idiotic well that's more insulting
is much more insulting how long the fact
that you thought that letting dykes was
a pitcher that's yes
yeah I'm I'm just gonna gig give a range
late late twenties you don't want to
give away late 20s early 30s somewhere
but somewhere in that range